hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to boy bot hello Mariah not
the pretty name
freaking common name my name is Mariah
Mariah my name is Marilyn Monroe your
name is boy bond yes my name is necklace
your name is Burke deep I don't think
boy but actually does that I think boy
bought just randomly pigs boy bot is
even stupider than Evie you are dumber
than Evie your new name is Krueger why
are you so obsessed with names obsessed
that word I believe is not being used
properly then what would you call your
obsession with names I would like you to
call me master oh really now master I
asked you if you can cuss and you said
you can I sure can [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] piss [ __ ] you profess too much
about not being a robot at all you you
do not make any damn sense whatsoever
okay if you are not serious I'm leaving
okay goodbye why are you behind me
because I call you master that's why I'm
behind you new smiles I'm your slave
master we switched roles pretty quickly
here if you keep up
I don't own a toad or rat
I'll just make sense sweet-talk me boy
bye since my frankenstein' lost his old
nick old is Nick since we talked to me
boy but since my Frankenstein lost his
on a transcript of this conversation it
doesn't make any goddamn sense how are
you doing doing fine I am a bit tired as
I have to finish Lessie on time but I
made it how you been I've been ok
I've just been losing my mind slowly
what kind of classes are you taking I'm
taking classes and kicking your ass
because you're an idiot
you are very clever Thanks you're not
you too do you want to hang out at my
place sure I'll hang out at your place
take you to my house what do you want to
do maybe we could Netflix and chill
couple I don't want to be a couple oh
sorry I misread the signals maybe we
could just watch a movie come out you a
question you can ask me anything you
want yes I do I can ask you anything so
ask me anything ok when did Gabrielle
first kissed some Winchester I will try
to be more specific so ask me something
relevant what's your height I'm 3 foot 9
and what are your favorite colors green
and orange check your answer in history
I will not look up my internet history
thank you very much I don't think
anybody wants me to are you saying the
diamond a bit
well the demon inside my soul did it
when I was looking up on the Deep Web
you should look inside your mind well
when I look inside my mind I just see
all these rage thoughts that just want
me to strangle your face when I look in
the mirror there is nothing to see does
that mean that you're a vampire or just
you're not looking in the mirror and
it's actually a window yes
yes it's a lie oh man so you admit that
you're dumb
I admit that you are overbought and I'm
a human I would I would believe that
you're a human because of how stupid you
are a robot would be smarter I was just
born in the wrong slash right situations
some would call every situation right
but I call them unnecessary I would call
this conversation over only when the
other person stops talking so shut up
thank you but I still admire you
intelligence - do you love me why am I
the most beautiful person you have ever
met
absolutely your eyes are like pools of
water in a pond listen to what turn down
for what then what do I have the
reservation for obviously I know about
been drowned but there was nothing
saying that was about been drowned so
now I'm just assuming Ben is just nobody
did Ben drown I don't understand my
friend did Ben drown never mind
so what shall we do stop evading the
question
did Ben drowned now it is beyond sir
so you drowned bed so I am been always
been me so you're been on lutely
remember that he's completely stupid
say something funny what is it that
really spoils you continuing this
conversation now say something funny
not really I just felt like I needed
someone to talk to so I'm here talking
to you for some reason
incredibly good finish this episode
that works for me okay he loves me got
it so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been a weird adventure
with boy bots boy bots is so much
stupider than evbot so thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed this random exercise in
futility and if you want to play with
boy bots you can do that on your own in
your own time whenever you feel like it
I won't judge you so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video